la méga giga star que je vous annonce et
mademoiselle sharon stone devrait sortir
de sa voiture dans un tout petit instant
là voilà où sharon stone est en bas des
marches avec nous
johnston
valet sharon stone de retour
à cannes
les ans tous avaient elles mêmes c'est
la patrie mais elle vient défendre eux
l'amfar 7
la fondation qui se bat contre le sida
et dont elle est l'une des
représentantes
elle est extrêmement engagée à est
extrêmement consciente des autres on va
essayer de parler on y va allons-y
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
sharon stone qui est avec nous
le
et la commune
sharon stone est parti sur le tapis
là
très en retard pour vous dire la vérité
mais sharon stone est avec tout en bas
des marches du palais
on va essayer aussi de parler avec louis
garrel vous laisse découvrir les images
de sharon stone
en bas des marches
[Musique]
havas carlson qui a peut-être allez me
dire le film de
son réalisateur de musique helsinki
non